Americans have missed out on 603 billion
dollars of free money over the past
eight years by doing this one thing and
let me show you just how much money 603
billion dollars is let's say this coffee
bean is worth two hundred fifty dollars
this is what one thousand dollars worth
of coffee beans looks like and this jar
is what about a million dollars worth of
coffee beans would look like and to
visualize 603 billion dollars you'd need
approximately 194 000 of these jars to
fill up a regulation football field and
it would take more than three full
football fields to make 603 billion
dollars that's a lot of coffee well
Americans have missed out on all this
because they've kept their money in
savings and money market accounts at the
five largest U.S banks instead of
putting it at a bank with one of the top
five highest yielding accounts I'm going
to explain how that amount is calculated
why people aren't moving their money and
why Savers could be losing a lot more
money in the future let's get into it so
here's how I did the math I got a list
of the highest yielding savings accounts
in the US from bankrate.com here are the
current top five
then I got data on the amount the bank
spent on savings and money market
accounts from the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation and then I asked
Nathan Stovall a principal analyst for
financial sector data s p Global Market
intelligence to help me boil it all down
to just the five largest banks by
deposits as of the third quarter those
Banks were holding more than 2.4
trillion dollars in consumer savings and
money market accounts about half the
total held on all commercial Banks I
found what that money could have earned
in a top high yield savings account and
subtracted it from what it actually
earned according to the bank's data then
I added up the total from each quarter
going back to 2014 when FDIC first
started tracking consumer deposits in
these accounts
[Music]
so why are consumers missing out on all
this free money
it's not because the big banks are any
safer since FDIC ensures consumer
deposits up to 250 000 on any bank they
cover your money is equally safe at any
FDIC insured Bank a tuck to Gary
Zimmerman the CEO of Max my interest a
company that helps consumers move their
money between the top high yield savings
accounts he told me many consumers don't
think it's worth the effort to switch
and many don't know about the superior
Alternatives also people don't think
critically about financial decisions
Zimmerman told me the big banks have
also invested billions of dollars into
consumer facing technology like Zell and
Mobile Banking that make it convenient
for consumers to use their accounts the
banks have invested heavily in this
technology because it's still way
cheaper than paying higher interest
rates and it's important to note that if
consumers did move out of the big banks
on a large scale the banks with the high
yield accounts could lower the rates no
one's quite sure what would happen
because it's so much money but consumers
should really think about making the
switch because they're likely to be
losing on even more money in the future
but the FED raising interest rates the
fastest pay since the 1980s Banks earn a
higher rate on their deposit accounts
than fed they're able to pass those
higher rates onto customers the ones
that don't are able to pocket that money
the third quarter of 2022 was the
largest gap between what Savers and high
yield accounts and those with accounts
of the big five earned an interest but
that difference will probably be dwarfed
in the fourth quarter because rates at
high yield banks have risen along with
big interest rate hikes from a fed and
if rates stay high through 2023 as
investors and the FED predict that will
mean even more money Savers miss out on
by staying at the big Banks so this pile
Savers are missing out on could grow a
lot bigger you may not have a lot in
savings now but you can do like
griselda's Benny The Butcher said on
Tana talk 4. turn these breadcrumbs to a
hedge fund that's all for now see you
next time
[Music]